[Musique]
dans le cadre du plan un million d'arbre
divers espèce indigène et Angélique ont
été plantés sur le site de la laisse pas
association laïque pour l'éducation la
formation la prévention est l'autonomie
à Saint-Pierre des espèces les
l'Arboretum à vocation semence hier
créer au sein de l' ESAT Gernez Rieux
une plantation avec de densité moins
large avec une certaine représentativité
d'espèces 36 ici pour être exact exact
120 plantes et donc les plans sont
plantés de sang tu as pouvoir disposer
de fruits assez rapidement et assez
abondamment donc quelques-uns des
individus pensée aujourd'hui pour enfant
pied d'ici 3 ou 4 années les autres à
l'horizon de 8 10 15 ans pour les plus
difficiles et ces espèces une fois
qu'elles sont en fautif y est pour ont
alimenté la Crémetterie les départements
et ses graines et riz Ora for effectif
de diffuser la semence à l'ensemble des
partenaires du pain maison dans
le département est
l'association propose chaque année au
moins un de ces établissements à la
collectivité pour porter l'opération de
plantation pas qui s'occupe des
personnes en situation de handicap
notamment et sa partenaire naturel et
aujourd'hui et bien nous avons lancé
complètement l'action c'est-à-dire que
la lève pas offre ses différents sites
pour planter ses espèces à travers les
arboretum notamment pour participer
complètement à l'action d'autre part
nous avons un marché réserver ça a
marché réservé pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
arbre dans le milieu du handicap il faut
savoir que la laisse pas à obtenir un de
ces marché réservé en quelques mots j'ai
envie de dire que on a compris
maintenant depuis quelques années que le
climat l'environnement la Visitation la
nature et nous avions à en prendre soin
et donc on prend soin du sol réunionnais
et de ce qui poussent de la même manière
que nous prenons soin des personnes
Jacques
après la plantation symbolique de
quelques plans Jean-Marie Virapoullé
Michel CARON visiter des exploitations
agricoles de l' ESAT dans la vanille
réserve de l'établissement
[Musique]